hi i'm malia i'm 15 years old hi i'm
katie and i am much older still and
today we are competing once again and
here are the rules for today's
competition number one you must make an
entree number two you must make a
dessert and number three it must be
something you would serve at a fancy
dinner party for influencers are you
taller than me now
are you
yes last time it was a lot of fun but i
lost and i'm really competitive and i
like to win but i did have a really good
time with malia like i feel like we
became friends it was a tough loss well
she was 12 so it didn't hurt but she was
also on masterchef hi i'm malia brower i
was a former contestant on masterchef
junior season seven and i'm so excited
to be competing again with katie the
last two and a half years have
totally been life-changing i mean i've
gone on three master chef
tours which have been really keeping me
busy sometimes i could be gone for six
to seven weeks i have not been traveling
been just mostly indoors mostly drinking
and making sourdough bread i
love dance so i do studio dance and i do
high school dance i think malia has been
having a glow up i mean katie last time
was absolutely incredible but i
definitely sharpened up my knives in the
kitchen i feel like my pastry skills
have evolved over the last couple years
because i've been doing a lot of
desserts i think i'm definitely a better
chef than i used to be
we'll use chef loosely i do want to win
i want to win so bad i don't need to win
but i need to win
you a lot of stuff
yeah
i'm blooming some gelatin my first step
is i'm just creaming some sugar and some
butter so you've been touring with
master chef yeah so like have you been
just like practicing every day like all
your culinary skills you're cooking
every single day for six weeks for six
weeks my next step i am going to be
combining some buttermilk heavy whipping
cream some greek yogurt some ube extract
it's the flavoring of the purple yam
that's grown in the philippines that is
delicious now i'm gonna cream this
together adding in a singular egg yolk
and some
vanilla and what i like to say is you
could literally never have too much
vanilla baking soda and baking powder
into my flour and give it a quick little
whisk it's crazy how quickly you've
grown up but you were always a little
bit like grown up like you know you're
always mature i'm gonna add some heavy
cream my gelatin some honey i love honey
and some sugar i'm going to be putting
my flour mixture into this bowl so what
is it like performing in front of a
crowd do they clap do you get standing
ovation i cook in my house there's no
cheering i'll come to your face you'll
come cheers thank you do you like have
friends over and cook with them back in
my prime time in middle school i used to
make cookies for everybody well they'd
have to pay for it how old were you
during your pride i was 12 years old at
12 years old i was in a pony club
right now i'm just getting a little glob
kind of making it into like a ball smash
it on in there with my knuckle are there
sugar cookies yeah you would normally
use like an actual crust i just find
that takes a lot longer and i also like
the taste of the sugar cookie better
well i'm just going to slowly
incorporate my warm mixture
into my ube mixture i'm going really
slow with my whisk because i'm trying
not to incorporate too many air bubbles
i want it to be nice and smooth is there
anything that you've been like getting
into during like the last two years that
i should know about like any
yeah hobbies i have been going to vegas
a lot in vegas
turning it
up i'm gonna put this through a mesh
strainer just to get out any clumps you
wanna make sure it's nice and smooth
after these are done just like this i'm
gonna put them in the oven for around
eight to ten minutes or until they get
golden brown i'm gonna pour my mixture
into some hoop glasses super pretty so
far if i get your approval i feel very
good till these in the fridge so what do
you do in vegas we're normally there for
just like a short period of time okay um
like three days or something for dance
more than three days in vegas is a long
time we'll stay the day in vegas go out
to brunch i was not doing that at 15. 15
i was like can we rent a blockbuster
movie that was like gonna be exciting
mix together my powdered sugar put my
cream cheese right in there mix it up so
katie do you go to vegas a lot no i mean
a couple times i'm i love the penny
slots well i am not finished with my
dessert but i need to get some pork
marinated okay
good job
luckily i just cleaned my surface i
think i've been cleaner than the last
time oh yeah definitely i love having a
clean space so in this marinade i have
achiote paste chili powder
garlic powder
salt pepper cumin oregano vinegar and
some pineapple juice add in some vanilla
and some lemon extract and i love adding
lemon extract because you could barely
taste it but it just adds so much so now
i'm going to add in some pork shoulder
about a pound
and let that marinate for as long as i
can i've done the crust my filling for
my dessert and now i'm just going to cut
up some
decor so like some strawberries some
kiwis i've made my like filling or like
the main part of my dessert um but now
i'm doing working on some toppings for
that and i've also marinated some pork
for my entree i wonder what you're
making for your entree
beware beware
so for
my topping i'm gonna combine some flour
brown sugar some oats some butter and i
think i'll do a whole pinch of salt i've
taken my mixture and i've spread it all
over my tray what influencers like would
be at this party could an influencer be
like like a celebrity yeah obviously i'd
like invite drake oh should we have
beyonce there oh beyonce yeah okay okay
that's like a mutual invite from us and
at my studio somebody's actually doing
hold up by beyonce not in that dance but
it's like literally one of my favorite
dances ever i took tap dance in college
nice which you want to see yes i do
oh
yeah how did i do
i would say use energy with their arms
with your fingers through your fingers
like coming out of your arm that yeah
out
yeah that's right
hop collab
that took me like three weeks to learn
so now i'm just cutting my kiwi chop it
in quarters i'm gonna do some petite
little slices do you know gordon ramsay
yes okay does he yell at people in real
life he will yell at you if you suck so
here don't even feed you
yeah
that's a perfectly ripe fluid so i'm
just gonna put these in the fridge to
let them cool now i'm gonna just start
cooking my potatoes add some sugar on
top and that's just gonna draw out like
the juices and sweeten it up so i have
chambord which is basically like a black
raspberry liqueur do you wanna try a
chambord
i need i can drink a little chicken
oh yeah kate's off to a pretty good
start well you inspired me last time we
cooked together i was like i gotta up my
game for more i gotta have some more
elements and you inspired me
i'm gonna go put this in the oven for
about 20-25 minutes and i'm gonna put
this in the fridge these entrees are
like super important so now i'm gonna
make my thick and cranberry sauce so i'm
just going to be adding pork twine we're
gonna add in some brown sugar some black
pepper figs spread you could use fake
jelly balsamic vinegar and then i'm
going to give it a little stir and then
after that i'll add in the beef stock
that sounds really fancy and delicious
i'm going to put this into
a pressure cooker and we're going to
make sure all of our marinade goes in
with it and then i'm gonna add some
pineapple guajillo chili pepper a little
bit of my favorite salsa which is like a
peach pineapple sauce that's a little
sweet just to add more moisture in there
make sure we don't burn the bottom of
the pressure cooker i love pineapple me
too okay i feel like we need to go out
to dinner like we like a lot of the same
house nobody's seven o'clock saturday
night oh my god i'm just kidding i'm
there though i'm there are you paying
taste you will pay oh yeah yeah yeah
tasty
yeah adding my cranberries and setting
it to low heat so now i just drain these
potatoes cut them in quarters and you
want them to be like really nice and
soft add nice generous pinch of salt
light cream and then some fontina cheese
i'm just going to put the lid on the
pressure cooker cook this on high for 25
minutes now i'm going to quick pickle
some red onions i'm going to add some
serrano peppers for heat now these are
all mashed up so i'm just gonna set them
aside i just want to whisk together the
oil and the vinegar a little bit my
vinegar olive oil mixture is
boiling i'm gonna just pour that over my
onions okay mix that together a little
bit and then i'm going to tear up some
mint leaves to go inside it now i'm just
going to make my mushroom and spinach
concoction so i just put some olive oil
in here adding my garlic and
onions in first and so then i'll add in
my mushrooms and my spinach and a little
bit of salt a trick is once you can
start like actually smelling the garlic
that's when you know that you should
start adding your other ingredients now
i'm going to add in my spinach i just
like to do like a quick little handful
i'll add more if i want to now we're
going to do some lime juice
cilantro do you like cilantro i'm not a
fan this is why i'm worried because it
can be like an alienating thing because
some people i think genetically it
tastes like soap right yeah and then i'm
gonna do some garlic in it mix this guy
together
i'm going for a very like creamy texture
that i can
put in a squeeze bottle and it's not
gonna get like stuck or lumpy in there
now i'm gonna be trying my
sauce my fig sauce would you like to try
love to try okay
and tell me what it needs if it needs
anything i'm sure it's gonna be oh
that's good thank you
okay yeah is it okay is it good holy cow
that's so good i don't think i was gonna
like it because there's cilantro oh
right okay you're not getting like i'm
not getting soap i'm gonna we're angry
i'm gonna cry that makes me so happy
so i'm gonna take my
avocado crema and put it into a squeeze
bottle potatoes are looking good so now
we're gonna start seasoning my fillets
so i'm just gonna do a generous amount
of salt a generous amount of garlic
powder and then some pepper and then i'm
gonna put it on here and then i'll
season it when it's in the pan on the
other side well i'm gonna grill up some
pineapple i'm going for like kind of
alpha store flavors do you think
there'll be any bricks that makes you
inviteless adele's gonna be there oh we
forgot about adele
yes do you think she'll make a song for
us i think so your food is so good
that's my adele impression
so it's like if i have kids is that
embarrassing to do something like that
my mom used to do that all the time
singing showing funny videos to my
elementary school crush of me as a baby
me and him never worked out look at that
nice sear on those stakes i'm gonna like
research too because one little more
yeah even
and i'm like really want some like dark
almost like charred bits i'm just
looking for that nice like dark brownish
color and then i'm gonna baste it the
insta pot just finished so i'm gonna
release the pressure
pull out the pepper turning the saute on
because i wanted to reduce some of the
liquid down and i'm going to start
shredding the pork with my two forks add
in my butter and i'm gonna start basting
it spacing is just when you like lock in
all the flavors you just pretty much go
like this you can add some herbs if you
want to i feel like we're really in the
heat of competition now yeah when you're
cooking at a dinner party you've got to
be pretty precise and you always want to
be just like a little nervous because
then if you're not and you're too
relaxed then you'll like forget things
and like mess up but just try to have
fun i love people coming in and like
making sure they get a drink whatever it
is maybe they get like a little snack i
love making like fun little mocktails oh
yeah i have cocktails like grown up
i'm just trying to get some color on my
tortillas straining out my
fig apricot sauce i have everything
ready and i'm just gonna try and take
these out i think it might be cool for
my tortillas to like be perfectly round
yeah i think that's pretty so i'm gonna
cut them just like a little bit smaller
so we're gonna add in our mixture so now
i'm just like gonna start assembling
with these
different fruits slice up just very tiny
little bits of pineapple i'm getting so
quiet cause i'm so focused i know me too
it's harder i want to talk but like it's
just like i'm in the zone i don't want
to add too much but i don't want to add
too little yeah you want to leave
anything like
on the floor sure the floor you want to
leave anything out on the field on the
field thank you thank you yes you want
to leave anything on the field i think
you want to leave everything you want to
leave everything on the field sure
you don't want to not leave something on
the field you need you need things on
the field yours is looking beautiful oh
my god yeah feeling a little nervous
right now i'm feeling nervous too don't
worry i'm gonna grab some of my pork now
and just like shake it off i'm going to
get some mashed potatoes on here i'm
gonna put my crema on top and add my
fillet on the butter mash so i'm gonna
add my spinach and mushroom mix you
never know how the judge is gonna be jen
harris is back she is one of the top
food writers in the country i'm really
hoping to impress her i'm gonna add my
pickled onions now basically i like
adding a lot of height to my dishes i
definitely hope i can impress her again
overall i'm just trying to like make
sure you get a mouthful of every part of
that i want you to taste you know she's
a tough judge she doesn't pull punches
now i'm gonna do this sauce
pretty nervous for this part because
this could either make or break it this
is the fig cranberry sauce
i'm doing some cilantro micro greens
here i'm just going to clean up my dish
you literally eat with your eyes first
so just always try and have a clean dish
everything's set which i'm very happy
about so i'm just adding the
strawberries and some of the juice of
the strawberry okay um flour flour you
gotta have the prettiest flower on there
you are not ready why is this so hard
for me maybe i lose the flower no i go
flower too many things are happening
there's one flower i'm just getting one
pop i think hers looks really nice
i'm scared
i need a flatter flower
but one with height you know what i'm
talking about all right
i'm happy with my entree and my dessert
yours looks gorgeous oh my god so does
yours we're gonna give these to jen next
yeah hopefully she likes them how are
you feeling so far with my dishes i'm
both feeling pretty good but jen's like
a really serious like food critic slash
judge yeah so i'm a little nervous but i
think we got there that's good i think
we both killed it so
let's just see what jen thinks i'm jen
harris and i'm a food columnist for the
l.a times once again i'll be judging
katie and malia's competition so
high-end party food should be something
that you wouldn't typically cook for
yourself at home so it should feel
special it should fill you up but not be
too filling and it should be instagram
friendly because you definitely want to
take a picture of it i'll be giving each
entree a score of one to five also i'll
be giving each dessert a score of one to
five so the best total score you can get
is a ten i have high expectations for
both katie and malia i think they're
extremely talented and i cannot wait to
see what they cook up let's start with
the entrees i have no idea which one of
you made
what there is clearly a taco situation
and a nice piece of meat clearly one is
more like a traditional take on a fancy
dinner and
a newer take on what might be considered
fancy i want to try the taco first
that was a whole lot of flavor there's a
really nice sauce and marinade in there
with some like good heat to it the
pineapple is like a really nice sweet
kick with the onion
there's some sort of creamy avocado
sauce there's like nice acid in there it
tastes like an al pastor taco you would
have at a fabulous food truck in la very
impressed with this also presentation
this looks very nice and definitely
fancy
that is also delicious the meat is
cooked perfectly the mashed potatoes are
a really nice fluffy texture and it's
kind of like
what you'd get at a steakhouse they're
both delicious
but i have to give like a half extra
point to this person
for the plating so i'm gonna give this a
4.5 and this one a four let's try the
desserts try the purple one first i do
like the color okay let me get a little
bit of everything in here
okay when i do eat dessert i want there
to be
a lot to mine there and to have a bunch
of different textures and flavors so
this is this is nice and that each bite
you kind of get something a little bit
different and this is something nice and
light and refreshing after the tacos so
this pairs nicely with it i'm going to
try the tart now
also nice because there's some citrus
in the cream so it's not too heavy it's
baked well it kind of just tastes like a
good butter cookie i honestly feel like
both exceeded and met the challenge
so please invite me to this party by the
way this is uh difficult
i am going to give this dessert
a four and a half this dessert is also
very good i'm gonna give this dessert
a4
okay we have a winner who i don't know
the winner
i won
finally finally i needed it we have both
one now congratulations katie um you
definitely deserved it i did win last
time so it is only fair that she won
this time i think malia is inspirational
i was really worried that she would feel
like a different person like when we saw
each other two years later but like it
just felt like we picked up where we
left off so seeing someone her age just
be so secure and so sweet it is
inspiring i just feel like we just get
each other katie's her old slam self
like super sweet super loving and
super funny and i just love hanging out
and cooking with her next time i'm
definitely coming back for that win
[Music]
you